[Musique]
bonsoir fois tu me colle merci d'être
avec nous en direct sur rt france jean
yves le drian qui est donc parti avec la
vie un message de fermeté vis-à-vis des
politiques
est ce qu'il va être entendu selon vous
bah écoutez je dis qu'il est vraiment le
bienvenu et nous nous vraiment nous
soutenons tous les efforts de la france
que la france fait pour le libor
finalement ce que la france est au liban
c'est bien plus que ce que le niveau des
fonds pour le liban pour le liban mais
pour répondre directement à votre
batterie sion s'ils devaient être
entendus ils auraient été entendus bien
avant les responsables auraient pu
entendre le président français emmanuel
macron qui a visité le liban après
l'explosion du 4 août qui a revisité le
liban un mois après qui a maintenu les
pressions donc je vais vous dire
malheureusement sans être ni pessimiste
ni optimiste mais être réaliste non
malheureusement je doute fort bien que
les responsables libanais écoute parce
que finalement leur position sur place
et de ne pas écouter et de faire
l'europe une vraie force française ou
autre dont tu peux malheureusement non
nous ne sommes pas très optimistes de la
visite du ministre français heni d'une
réaction directe des responsables
libanais à vous suivre ça veut dire
qu'il ya une vraie volonté française
emmanuel macron d'abord jean yves le
drian aujourd'hui mais finalement
quasiment aucune marge de manoeuvre
écoutez là la volonté française date
depuis des décennies depuis les années
1800 quand ils ont arrêté les les
batailles entre les maronites et les
druzes ensuite à la première guerre
mondiale puis à free la deuxième donc
c'est des relations vraiment historique
politique sécuritaire après la deuxième
guerre mondiale qui a empêché les
troupes allemandes donc ce n'est pas
nouveau durant la guerre fraticide du
liban la france est intervenue
directement quand le premier ministre
avait ri a été entre guillemets arrêté
en arabie séoudite donc finalement le
support français n'est pas n'est pas
nouveau pour le liban mais je peux dire
qu'aujourd'hui finalement il ya quand
même une place politique est implanté
depuis plus que trente années qui est au
pouvoir dans des milices dans des
divisions sectaires qui est là qui a
bâti quand même un eldorado basé sur la
corruption basé sur des pouvoirs
vraiment divisés sur une division
complète donc aujourd'hui à mon avis il
faut beaucoup plus que des pressions ou
des discours français
européens et américains il faut je dire
des sanctions il faut des pressions ils
font une conférence internationale
automatique et je dis bien pour un
changement réel sinon ces personnes là
qui sont au pouvoir sont dans leur zone
de confort ils sont bien chez eux ils
ont les fonds qu'ils gèrent bien ils
peuvent même regagné des élections mais
même de l'élection ne sont pas ne sont
pas le cas donc honnêtement il faut bien
plus que ça et je commencerai bien qu'il
faut déjà mettre en application les
pressions en tout cas française et
européenne
ils sont des sanctions fiscales des
sanctions monétaires sur tout ce
groupement politique je dirais bien à
grand à grande échelle pour commencer à
les sortir de la zone de confort sinon
nous nous attendons nous attendons à
aucun changement
malheureusement direct il est une fois
de plus bien sûr qu'on apprécie
énormément et les pressions françaises
on les a fuis au nez aux côtés mais on
sait qu'on a une classe politique qu'on
connaît très bien et qui ne bougera pas
en tout cas sans dépression vraiment
réelles qui font mal et qui sa frappe où
ça bouge qui sont vraiment les positions
monétaire à savoir que cette classe
politique est la seule qui a pu sortir
son argent du pays à savoir pendant un
contrôle de capitaux très fort et est
vraiment pour les sortir de leur zone de
confort il faut vraiment touché sur
leurs fonds en dehors de du pays jean
yves le drian a rencontré les
représentants de plusieurs partis
d'opposition
il ya un consensus à la seule issue de
crise possible et la mise en place d'un
gouvernement indépendant depuis le temps
qu'on en parle pourquoi est ce si
compliqué de le mettre en place ce
gouvernement écouter parce que
finalement pour mettre en place un
gouvernement avant qu'ils sont
indépendants euros c'est que toutes les
les problèmes politiques les divisions
qui empêche la formation de le goût du
gouvernement ce sont les mêmes policiers
un problème qui seront pris à
l'intérieur du gouvernement finalement
gouvernement d'indépendants ou de
technocrates
malheureusement ne peut pas voir le jour
ça fait huit mois que nous le voyons pas
ce que des pressions politiques énormes
au niveau interne mais au niveau 6 au
niveau régional est ce que j'aimerais
dire aussi c'est que le grand plan c'est
de voir quoi
après le gouvernement parce que si c'est
le gouvernement pour y revenir pour
qu'il va être gelé pour la même façon ou
la formation a été gelé on sera toujours
sur une lettre morte
l'idée c'est de venir sur un plan très
clair qui dit intervention immédiate du
fonds monétaire international sans ça on
n'aura pas de fond qui dit finalement
négociations immédiates avec les
bailleurs de fonds au niveau interne qui
sont les banques et les dépositaires qui
ont presque perdu leur argent et au
niveau international ces bailleurs de
fonds qui ont acheté des bons de trésor
en euros autres donc le plan est très
clair mais honnêtement il n'y a aucune
volonté politique à l'inter qui a
complètement une division
je dirais secteur un politique dont on
ne voit surtout pas une lueur d'espoir
et bien sûr nous savons que nous payons
le prix aussi de division je dirais
régionales avec les nouvelles puissances
régionales de la région l'arrivée du du
président américain sur nouvelle
politique et négociations iranienne le
rôle de l'arabie séoudite les élections
si réel et tous ces problèmes bien sûr
qu'ils ont une flash longues pattes
repas une plateforme parfaite de
division au liban et nos partis
politiques suivent les uns et les autres
en priorité sans mettre la priorité de
leur peuple qui est vraiment en
perdition totale
vous parlez de sanctions sur le
porte-monnaie en quelques mots tout à
l'heure mais pour le moment il n'y a ni
nom ni chiffres concernant les
responsables sur lesquels pèsent ces
sanctions de la part de la france ça
veut dire quoi paris essaye de sauver la
face
écoutez je n'espère pas moi je suppose
je vais être plus optimiste je suppose
que les sanctions ont besoin quand même
d'une étude bien détaillé je suppose que
les sanctions monétaires et économiques
doivent passer entre la france et l
union européenne pour être direct on a
vu ça avec les sanctions américaines sur
le mague mystikal donc je suppose qu'ils
ont besoin de plus de préparation mais
plus de préparation on veut dire qu'on a
un peuple vraiment en perdition donc
j'espère vraiment pas que c'est pour
sauver la face j'espère vraiment que
c'est une phase préparatoire mais on est
obligé vous voyez pas ce que crier tous
les jours au loup et finalement ne pas
appliquer directement ne va faire que
renforcer ses politiques qui met mieux
aujourd'hui ne vont plus y croire donc
j'espère vraiment que c'est pas vraiment
pour sauver la face et que c'est un
report technique ce qu'on l'espère en
tout cas au liban mais il faut à tout
prix encore une fois frappé fort même
des pressions internationales parce que
je vais vous dire vraiment au liban nous
sommes otages
nous sommes aujourd'hui otage un système
politique le peuple libanais les
entreprises et malaises sont otages
vraiment un système qui tient vraiment
toutes les rênes du pouvoir et qui est
prêt vraiment à tous on veut surtout pas
nouveau confiée au leap seront par une
guerre au liban au nez otage d'un
système est seulement les pressions
internationales
aurons nous sortir de nos mails merci à
vous merci fois de ce mot comme d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france